[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
in 1986 down booth released the animated
classic and American tale with an
aggressive yet still heartfelt tone it
Chronicle the lives of a family
separated use clever commentary to
display the expectations versus the
reality of immigrants arriving in
America and show the power of the
fighting spirit to locate what you
thought was lost forever
and then the sequel came out it's a
cowboy movie released in 1991
Fievel goes west clearly has little
connection with the original in terms of
tone animation even the people who made
it and instead decides to make a goofy
Western I don't know why this movie
exists why they took this angle with it
where life fate was so cruel to make it
Jimmy Stewart's last role but here we
are does it have any charm brilliance or
charisma on par with the original did
John Cleese turn down the role of
codsworth to play the villain in this
instead let's take a look at 500 euros
West it opens with a fantasy fight fool
is having about his hero Wylie burp
Jimmy Stewart's last character is named
Wylie burp can we just save this voice
over is his last appearance bitch home
cookin soup it's not much more dignity
so Wylie burp is surrounded by the
cactus cat gang until fifl comes in to
save the day it's too tough kid get out
while you still can you can still have a
good sequel leave this one to the
director video market despite the style
being different it is still very good
animation it just doesn't allow itself
to capture the charm of the original in
fact it openly stops it half the time
like when Tanya tries to sing somewhere
out there from the last film
[Music]
throw some fruit for work are there
actual human people in the city who are
like lousy james horner singing mice I
substitute questioning this with
throwing produce it also looks like
Tonya's gone through kind of a growth
spurt looking more like a teenager now
despite her looking close to the same
age as her brother in the first maybe
it's the same altering fro support the
National Lampoon's Vacation kids go
through I thought things would be better
in America in Russia my violins were
famous at least we never went hungry I
mean cool indeed we were on fire but my
violin yo the train there under messes
up their house you'd think they'd be
more prepared for that living under
there well five foals friend tiger
voiced again by Dom DeLuise says goodbye
to his feline love named miss kitty
who's going west how do I say this I
just want a cat who's more like a dog
isn't like a seal thing she wants
someone like a shark and because the
first film opened with a cat attack why
not this one too except where the first
one had oppressive rushing commentary
this one has John Cleese in a monocle
commentary fifl like a dumbass thinks he
can fight them transforming his blue hat
into a white cowboy hat I don't know
it's stranger the fact that's such a
huge symbol from the last film has
turned into a throwaway joke we're that
five fools they're probably never
realized it could do that oh my god I
gotta turn that thing inside out and
sold it for a fortune how do the
mechanics of that work the mice get
scared into the sewers where they come
across well look at that and everyday
ordinary Mouse they can trust the
frontier cats and mice help each other
Cleese his character named Carter wall
tells them that out west mice and cats
get along and he convinces them all to
buy tickets to head out there
Tiger finds out too late though and
tries to find the train that fight foals
families going on he gets chased by dogs
though for over two minutes
[Music]
cat got your tongue no but he's got way
too much screen time and because we need
another no cats in America song laughing
New York City instantly lost me next no
garbage if I was right the first time
well on the train though fifl comes
across caterwaul and here's his evil
plan of course we will eat the mice but
only after we have exploited their
labors yeah actually
Chet why is there legit commentary in
this and I was just too young to realize
it I really don't want to say this
clever satire in a film like this can I
selfishly ignore the good part of a film
just this once
the villains stumble across fifl though
and make it look like you fell off the
train so the other mites don't alter
their plans
so to court the hangover sequels it
happened again fifl has lost and
separated from his family
honestly it's such a cliff note in this
version that while I'm the original they
mourn for several days here they don't
even give a solid minute I think we got
lucky Norma ma this is what the land of
opportunity looks like I mean a little
spit and polish light a Sun denial
whatever I wonder if they invented
sarsaparilla yet caterwaul dupes the
mice into helping him build the beat up
town into a sunny paradise as fifl tries
his best to get home to his family he
even comes across tiger and they both
confuse each other for a mirage see kids
that's what happens when you drink
cactus juice Tiger is captured by tribal
my soul Viswa age well and namazu panda
yatta
[Music]
just get to the part where they confuse
him for God why is it every tribe in
everything mistakes what they've never
seen as a god Wow I've never seen this
marker before it must be God fifl comes
across Tiger though and Tiger shows them
how to get to town the only reason I'm
not a moccasin right now is because they
think I'm a god I'll join you as soon as
that game there's so many more
stereotypes to be explored here I'm not
sure we got to the cannibalism part yet
tiger tells him to just hop on a
tumbleweed which apparently has really
great GPS for towns in the middle of
nowhere as the animals sing rawhide
because I don't know westerns that song
was supposed to be sung by the good ol
boys sure enough fifl arrives at the
town making the entire time he's been
lost in this movie just 12 minutes
even the family doesn't really look that
relieved to see him it's great to see
you but we got a rope to pull and we
already used up all our emotion for this
scene in the last film what were you
even gone in this one Fievel tries
telling them about the cat's evil plan
but nobody believes them because why
should they believe the cue to get rid
of all the cats originally anyway
the cats of course reveal their evil
plan again in front of fight full
showing how a giant mousetrap is gonna
turn them all into mouseburgers holding
auditions just ignore that last part
about turning you all into mouseburgers
you all fell for a British puppet
pretend to be a cowboy I'm assuming
you're pretty dumb fight fool sticks a
fork in him though leading to well I'll
let the scene speak for itself
is there a word that exists to describe
how uncomfortable that was I don't think
there is so I'm just gotta make one up
that was an accident
that was a very unequal scene I'm a
cannibal
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
so cat our walk here's Tanya singh and
falls in love with her voice so he takes
her to miss kitty to transform her into
a star and says who you can be whatever
you want if you just believe in yourself
except in a good sequel that ship has
sailed
cat our wall previews her on stage as
fifl tries to escape one of his henchmen
[Applause]
[Music]
what was up with seeing through her
dress there for a second that was a
little uncomfortable I mean I wasn't
comfortable as this that wasn't
equitable I have to be honest it drives
me nuts how catchy this goddamn song is
when you hear it once it's in your head
for the rest of the day
it sounds like the beef it's what's for
dinner song except with the leprechaun
on crack playing the fiddle I like my
American tail songs to be a little more
off-key thank you very much
Fievel realizes he has no one to turn to
which is kind of ironic as being gone
for a while the family just kind of
abandons in through most of the movie so
he talked to a lazy dog who eventually
figures out is his hero Wylie burp what
the sleeping dog lie son is now what he
said the first time he was off at this
movie he tells him he's too old to stop
the cat's himself but he could train a
younger dog to fight for him since dog
spelled backwards is God I guess that
means Tiger is qualified so he agrees to
be trained by them leading to probably
one of the film's strangest lines even
one can be a god but it takes great to
be a dog there's so much weird in that
sentence I don't even know how to tackle
it I guess I'll just say it's dumb so
they meet in the desert and Wylie burp
teaches him how to be a dog you want to
intimidate someone lazy oh don't do it
too much my had a sailor friend to face
himself that way Tiger gives it a try
leading to sounds I guarantee you'll
hear in your nightmares tonight it
sounds like the fronts of torture Han
Solo makes an Empire Strikes Back
[Music]
Tyger go through all the training and
the three of them walk into town to stop
the cats cat our walls ready to set off
the giant mousetrap in the slowest
ribbon cut in history but our hero
stopping like any classic Western
instead of guns they use slingshots but
they don't seem to work so they use the
lazy eye so how many animators were
having seizures while making this don't
make me use the only actual gun we have
in this old western town and that's
pretty embarrassing when a spider is
holding you hostage unless that thing is
written by jr. token I don't see why
this should be an issue tiger saves her
though and they use the mousetrap as a
catapult doesn't matter if the puns
intended and cat our wall gets caught up
by the same disturbing woman from before
[Music]
that wasn't nearly as an actionable as
before but still you so the day is saved
as I'm assuming nuclear water causes the
plant life to grow that fast and they
had themselves a good old-fashioned
hootenanny squeak hey I'm almost near
the end I'm not working long in the joke
when freedom it's around the corner
the almost fitting irony is the final
words of Jimmy Stewart in this movie are
actually kind of beautiful when you
realize this is his last role just
remember Fievel one man sunset is
another man's dog I don't know what's
out there you know
those hills but if you ride yonder heart
open I think one day you'll find that
you're the hero you've been looking for
it's been four years I'm not letting
Fievel goes west get to me on the Sam
hell did you do that oh who cares check
out this amazing CGI effect that will
show off before any other anime about
dog honesty and that was an American
tale fifl goes west it's definitely not
the first one honestly it's fine for
just a little kids movie it's visually
interesting animated well colorful
energetic but it's still an American
tale film it has a high standard to live
up to and it simply doesn't do it if you
just want to give your kid something
goofy to watch it's fine for that but if
anyone is looking for something deeper
you're riding the wrong horse into the
sunset
[Music]
not now Nostalgia Critic I remember so
you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing
child find of America child find of
America is a national not-for-profit
organization that provides outstanding
professional services designed to
prevent and resolve child abduction and
the family conflicts that can lead to
abduction and abuse it receives calls
for help from searching parents parents
in conflict family members law
enforcement Child Welfare and other
allied agencies at-risk youth and
educators with an active caseload of
more than six thousand plans on any
given day their case managers are
serving dozens of families in crisis
each year the positivity impacts the
lives of thousands of children and
directly assists several hundreds more
in complex issues involving locating
returning or keeping them in safe
environments if you look at their site
you can see all the children they've
helped save and all the families they've
helped to heal and with an A+ rating on
charity watch it's among one of the best
out there click on the link and please
donate to the children and families who
need the most support
[Music]
you